let me tell you something about Lucky
Charms okay yeah they're magically
delicious but what else I I will I want
to give you I just want to give like a a
nod for what I do like about them
because I think they're maybe the only
cereal that if you ate dry it's still
good it's a snack it's it's a snack it
is and if you pull the marshmallows out
and just had it look at that oh my God
two and a half pounds to thirty dollars
should keep one in the office there is
not an item in the baked goods world
where cinnamon isn't a star is there a
better cereal milk than Cinnamon Toast
Crunch there is no better is that right
what milk is gonna taste better Fruit
Loops no look at 2010 look he looks like
a complete sociopath here they banned it
looks like a murderer in there they
found shrimp and uh Cinnamon Toast
Crunch I don't remember that at all it
was like two years ago I you know what
I'd still eat that box no throw the
straw and Rice-A-Roni one time I swear
to God